how much we suffered because of what did
not happen
but could only happen
the honesty of people
does not increase with their wealth
never buy a thing
seduced by its cheapness
such a thing in the long run
will cost you dearly
i do not take a single paper nor read
one a month
and i feel infinitely happier for it
i do not bite at the bait of pleasure
till you know there is no hook beneath
it
honesty is the first chapter of the book
of wisdom
the man who reads nothing at all
is better educated than the man who
reads nothing but newspapers
the most valuable of all talents is that
of never using two words when one will
do
i'm a greater believer in luck
and i find the harder i work the more i
have of it
do you want to know who you are
don't ask
act
action will delineate and define you
history in general
only informs us what bad government is
if a nation expects to be ignorant and
free
in a state of civilization it expects
what never was
and never will be
the whole art of government consists in
the art of being honest
i would rather be exposed to the
inconveniences attending too much
liberty
than to those attending too small a
degree of it
i think one travels more usefully when
they travel alone
because they reflect more
i was bold in the pursuit of knowledge
never fearing to follow truth and reason
to whatever results they led
to compel a man to furnish funds for the
propagation of ideas
he disbelieves and abhors is sinful and
tyrannical
tyranny is defined as that which is
legal for the government but illegal for
the citizenry
i like the dreams of the future
better than the history of the past
when injustice becomes law
resistance becomes duty
[Music]
every day is lost in which we do not
learn something useful
man has no nobler or more valuable
possession than time
our liberty depends on the freedom of
the press
and that cannot be limited without being
lost
i hold it that a little rebellion now
and then is a good thing
and as necessary in the political world
as storms in the physical
banking institutions are more dangerous
to our liberties than standing armies
be polite to all
be intimate with few
the natural progress of things is for
liberty to yield
and for the government to gain ground
i prefer dangerous freedom over peaceful
slavery
he who permits himself to tell a lie
once
finds it much easier to do it the second
time
the only security of all
is in the free press
i have no ambition to govern men
it is a painful and thankless office
[Music]
it is era alone which needs the support
of the government
truth can stand by itself
commerce with all nations alliance with
none
should be our motto
an honest man can feel no pleasure in
the exercise of power over his fellow
citizens
pride cost us more than hunger thirst
and cold
the dead should not rule the living
an enemy generally says and believes
what he wishes
it is reasonable that everyone who asks
justice
should do justice
he who knows best
knows how little he knows
don't try to do more good than people
can handle
he who gives up his freedom for security
receives neither
dissent is the highest form of
patriotism
saving on advertising is like stopping a
clock to save time
am convinced that the soul of every
person rejoices when he does good to
another
don't spend money you don't have
if you are angry
mentally count to ten before you speak
if you are very angry
count to one hundred
laws are written for ordinary people
so they must be based on ordinary rules
of common sense
laws must go hand in hand with the
progress of the human soul
the tree of freedom needs to be watered
from time to time
with the blood of patriots and tyrants
this is natural fertilizer for it
the sermon should be our lives
not our words
nothing gives more advantages over
others
than the ability to remain calm and cool
in any situation
constant vigilance is the price of
freedom
for the most part
people are more inclined to suffer than
to fight to remove the cause of
suffering
there is nothing more unequal
than the equal treatment of unequal
people
the profession of a lawyer consists in
questioning everything
disagreeing with everything
and talking endlessly
only two people will tell the truth
about you
your mother
and your enemy
in matters of style
go with the flow
in matters of principle
stand firm as a rock
a coward is much more likely to see
quarrels than a man of courage
for the selfish spirit of commerce
there is no homeland
no feelings
no
principles only profit